شكرا للزميل نايف اعزائي المشاهدين اسعد
الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مستمرون في تغطيتنا
للتطورات الدراماتيكيه في السودان حيث
تبادل الجيش وقوات الدعم السريعه
الاتهامات بشان خرق هدنه الايام الثلاثة
وقد افاد مراسل العربيه باندلاع الشبكات
بالاسلحه الثقيله سمعت اصداؤها في محيط
مبنى التلفزيون بام درمان
حيث رصد تحليق للطيران الحربي في اجواء
المدينه
هذا وتتواصلوا عمليات الاجلاء التي تقوم
بها الدول العربيه والغربيه لنقل رعاياها
من السودان وسط مخاوف من عمليه نزوح
سودانيه واسعه جراء المواجهات المستمره
حيث توقعت الامم المتحده نزوح نحو 270
الفا من السودان نحو تشاد وجنوب السودان
في وقت بات نحو خمسه عشر مليون سوداني
بحاجه الى دعم انساني عاجل
[موسيقى]
السودان
هذا واصدر الجيش السوداني بيانا شجب خلاله
الخروقات العديده التي اقترفها الدعم
السريع للهدنه حسب تعبيره
الجيش قال ان مجموعات الدعم السريع
تواصلوا تحركاتها داخل وخارج الخرطوم برغم
الهدنه
حيث رصد الجيش تحركات لارتال عسكريه متجهه
من غرب السودان الى الخرطوم اضافه الى
محاولات مجموعات من الدعم السريع السيطره
على مصفى الجيل للتحكم بالوقود الجيش
اتهمت دعم السريع ايضا باستغلال الهدنه
لانقاذ موقفها العملياتي الذي وصفه
بالمتدهور عبر نشر قناصه في الخرطوم
وولايات اخرى
هذا واظهرت الصور اعزائي المشاهدين مشاهد
تظهر حجم الدمار في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم جراء المعارك الدائره منذ اكثر من
عشره ايام
[موسيقى]
وفي المقابل اتهمت قوات الدعم السريع قوات
الجيش باستهداف مواقعها قرب القصر
الجمهوري بالخرطوم وقال بيان الدعم السريع
ان هذا الاستهداف يعد انتهاكا للهدنه
المعلنه مؤكدا ان القصف العشوائي للجيش
يهدد حياه المدنيين ورعايه الدول الاجنبيه
في الخرطوم كما اشارت قوات الدعم السريع
في بيان الله الى ان كسر شروط الهدنه
المعلنه يؤكد وجود اكثر من مركز قرار داخل
قياده الجيش
واعاد الدعم السريع التاكيد على التزامه
بشروط الهدنه لفتح ممرات انسانيه للمدنيين
والمقيمين الاجانب
[موسيقى]
في المقابل دانت وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه
ما وصفته باستمرار نهج قوات الدعم السريع
باستهداف السفراء والدبلوماسيين ومقر
البعثات الدبلوماسيه
ووصف بيان الخارجيه السودانيه قوات الدعم
السريع بانها ميليشيا ارهابيه بات الضلعه
في ترويع المواطنين وقتل واستهداف
المدنيين
البيان حذر من استغلال الدعم السريع
للهدنه في نشر قواته وارتكاب مزيد من
الانتهاكات بحق المدنيه
الخارجيه السودانيه اكدت التزام الجيش
بالهدنه حرصا على حمايه المدنيين واحترام
القانون الدولي
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
المزيد من المتابعه اذهب الى الخرطوم الان
ينضم الي من هناك مراسل العربيه سالم
الهاشمي سالم اهلا وسهلا بك جديد المشهد
الميداني واخر التطورات وهل هنالك التزام
تام بالهدنه سالم ام لا هذا الالتزام هش
جدا
سالم هل تسمعني
يبدو ان فقدنا الاتصال مع السالم الهاشمي
بالطبع لنا عوده اليه فور جهوز الاتصال من
جديد من جانبه طالب مسؤول السياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع بالالتزام في
الهدنه التي اعلناها لمده 72 ساعه بشكل
كامل
وقال برل في تغريده الله على تويتر ان
الهدف هو التوصل لوقف دائم للاعمال
العدائيه واقامه ممرات انسانيه لحمايه
المدنيين
اعود الى سالم الهاشمي من الخرطوم سالم
اذا كنت تسمعني اولا اهلا وسهلا بك جديد
المشهد الميداني واخر التطورات وهل هنالك
التزام تام بالهده من قبل الطرفين ام لا
هذا الالتزام هش جدا
نعم اهلا وسهلا بكم بكل الساده المشاهدين
الالتزام ها
شم بعد
الانباء التي تتواجد الينا بين الفين
والاخرى من وقوع اشتباكات في مناطق متفرقه
من العاصمه الخرطوم او من المناطق التي
تجدد فيها الاشتباكات قبل قليل
اصوات لرصاص وكذلك مدافع فقيده وخفيفه
بمحيط الاذاعه والتلفزيون وكذلك
سمع ايضا حركه لمجموعه من الطائرات في هذه
المنطقه بالتحديد وهي بالقرب من البعو
التلفزيون في منطقه كذلك سمع ايضا مجموعه
من الرصاص حلقاتها الرصاص وكذلك مضادات
الطائرات في منطقه بحري والمناطق الاخرى
كذلك
الاوضاع في محيط مقر القياده العامه كيف
يمكن وصفها سالم
في محيط القياده العامه وكل منطقه الخرطوم
في وسط الخرطوم هذه المناطق
بالامس شهدت هدوءا نسبيا في عدم تجدد
اطلاق النار لكنها اليوم ايضا تجددت فيها
اطلاق النار لكن هي الان باتت شبه خاليه
من المواطنين ونتحدثون عن المناطق السكنيه
التي هي بالقرب من القياده العامه ليست
بعيده من القياده العامه هذه المناطق الان
بدل السكري يخرجون من هناك
نازحين او لاجئين
ايا كان الولايات قريبه او الى خارج
السودان كذلك ربما هذه الاشتباكات اليوم
هي تؤكد ان هذه الهدنه ايضا اخترقت هل
هنالك اي حديث عن تمديد محتمل للهدنه ام
حتى الساعه الامور غير واضحه سالم
هي الهدنه اصلا قررت ب 72 ساعه ما زال
فيها يومين هذا اليوم الاول منها مازال
هناك يومان من هذه الهدنه لكن هل يمكن ان
ان تكون بقيه الهدنه مثل بدايتها هذا هو
هذا هو الاشكال
طيب
خلال هذا اليوم وبالامس هل تمكن اي فريق
اي طرف من التقدم على الطرف الاخر في وسط
العاصمه ام لا ما زالت خطوط التماس كما هي
لم يستطع اي طرف التقدم على الاخر
هي الاشتباكات على الارض يعني ليست كثيره
بذلك المعنى غالبيه هذا الاشتراكات تكون
او تبادل اطلاق النار لا يكون على الارض
كثيرا الا في محيط القياده العامه ومناطق
معينه وهي المناطق التي فيها التماس بين
الجانبين لكن المناطق مثل منطقه بحري مثل
ايضا المناطق التي في ام درمان كذلك نجد
فيها تمركز القوات السريع وهناك استهداف
لمواقع هذه القوات من قبل
سلاح او طيران لتابع للجيش السوداني وهو
يستهدف هذه المواقع وهي تتبادل معه ايضا
في مضادات الطائرات احيانا حينما يكون
هنالك تمشيط للجيش السوداني تتجدد هذه
الاشتباكات بعنف في كل المناطق التي تتمر
فيها قوات الدعم السريع طيب سالم هل استغل
من تبقى من المواطنين في الخرطوم هذه
الهدنه للخروج وتصريف اعمالهم او امورهم
الحياتيه نحن نعرف ان الاوضاع يعني سيئه
جدا هل لاحظت ان بعض الناس خرجوا لمتابعه
شؤونهم
ام ماذا
نعم منذ الامس وقبله كذلك بدات حركه
للمواطنين للخروج من المناطق التي تتجدد
فيها الاشتباكات ابتداء كنزوح او اللجوء
واما بقيه المناطق ففيها حركه شبه طبيعيه
لكن تنقصها بعض الخدمات هذا الحرص من
المواطنين في اني يتحصلوا على ما يحتاجونه
من هذه المناطق المختلفه سواء كان بيتعلق
الغذائيه او حتى غيرها من الامور التي
يحتاجونها الان سالم ماذا عن حركه النزوح
سواء في الداخل او باتجاه المناطق
الحدوديه او الدول المجاوره اذا كان لديك
اي متابعه حول هذا الملف
عما حركه النزوح تبدو كبيره وتزداد
تايرتها يوما بعد اخر كل يوم نجد ان
الاعداد تبدا بزياد بالنسبه للمواطنين
الذين يبحثون عن النزوح من هذه المناطق
بشكل كبير
على عهدنا مستوياته حتى الخروج من مناطق
الاشتباك الى المناطق التي تعد امنه نسبيا
في بعض المناطق في ام درمان وكذلك في
اطرافها يعني وفي الخرطوم كذلك وفي مدينه
بحري ايضا في اطراف هذه المدن وربما تكون
هنالك حركه الاشتباك اقل والنسبه الخطوره
اقل كذلك هذا بالاضافه الى الخروج من
ولايه الخرطوم اصلا الى ولايه مجاوره يضاف
اليها ايضا خروج من السودان بشكل عام في
حركه لجوء ايضا الى جمهوريه مصر العربيه
كذلك اثيوبيا وايضا حرص من المواطنين على
ان خاصه الذين قرروا ان يكونوا خارج
السودان هناك حرص شديد منهم وهناك ايضا
معاناه يعانيها هؤلاء المواطنين فيما
يتعلق بالاسعار الحركه نفسها
تتزامن هذه الامور كلها مع ازمه وقود
واضحه ازمه ايضا في
السيارات التي يمكن ان تقبلها المواطنين
كل هذه الازمات تتراكم على الموا
سالم الهاشمي مراسل العربيه من الخرطوم
شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه المتابعه الان
اعزائي المشاهدين نستمع الى كلمه لوزير
الخارجيه اللبنانيه عبد الله ابو حبيب من
داخل مطار بيروت الدولي في استقباله
للنازحين اللبنانيين الذين شاركت المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
في اجلائهم من عدد من مدن الخرطوم من
السماء الى ما يقوله عبد الله ابو حبيب
كل البدر رجعوا ونحنا
ممنونين للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
والامارات العربيه المتحده اللي ساعدونا
انه نوصلهم لهون اعطوهم الاولويه
للبنانيين وبدي اقول كمان انه الاردن
ساعدنا
وعرض علينا انه بس كان عنده امكانيه ضعيفه
انه ياخذنا بالطيران الحربي تبعه فنحن
مشينا مع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وكانوا كتير
كتير كتير مساعدين لالنا يعني ما بتعرفوا
درجه المساعده اللي يعطونا اياها
السعوديين
على على البورد
وعنده الخليه ازمه عم تشتغل حقيقه بتنظيم
يعني نحن لبنانيه لازم نحسن منه ونتعلم
ونشتغل ونشتغل مثلهم
هذه النقطتين بدي اقولهن اذا عندكم اسئله
مستعدين نجاوبون نحن
لا طبعا مش الكل موجودين احنا اللي ساعدنا
انه كان في كتير لبنانيين موجودين هون
بسبب الاعياد
اعاده اللبنانيين حول الميه ميه وشوي
راح نكونوا مطلعين واحد بين بين امبارح
وبين من الاحد لليوم يعني فلذلك اذا في
ناس بعد التلفونات موجوده اهلهم موجودين
يتصلوا فينا وبنجرب
بمعونه هون الحاج سعد الله بياتي انه
نجيبهم
[موسيقى]
منروح مع بلدان ثاني بنعمل جروبات ثاني
ومنجي
من جانبه قال وزير الخارجيه لبريطاني جيمس
كليفري انه تحدث مع طرفي الصراع في
السودان مؤكدان انه سيواصل الضغط على
القوتين من اجل الالتزام بوقف دائم لاطلاق
النار
لقد تحدثت بشكل مباشر ومن خلال وسطاء مع
الاطراف المتصارعه وقمت بدعوتهم الى
السماح باجلاء المواطنين البريطانيين
ومزدوجه الجنسيه والاطفال وسنواصل الضغط
من اجل الالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار بالطبع
من المستحيل ان نتنبا بالوقت الذي سيستمر
فيه الهدوء ونحن ندعو مواطنينا الى ترك
الاولويه للاشد حاجه الى الاجلاء
ايضا ان الوضع ما يزال خطيرا ومتقلبا ولا
يمكن التنبؤ به في السودان
بالعصيده
خلال الايام القليله الماضيه قمنا بتخطيط
مكثف عبر الادارات الحكوميه ومع شركائنا
الدوليين للاستفاده من اي تحسن في الوضع
على الارض للبدء في اجلاء الرعايه
البريطانيين في السودان يسعدني جدا اعلان
وقف اطلاق النار من قبل قاده الفصائل على
الارض وبالتالي بدانا عمليات الاجلاء من
المهم ان نتذكر انه تم خلق كل اعلانات وقف
اطلاق النار سابقا وبالتالي فان الوضع لا
يزال خطيرا ومتقلبا ولا يمكن التنبؤ به
هذا وضع مقطع فيديو استقبال اهالي ولايه
الجزيره التي تقع في المنطقه الشرقيه
الوسطى من السودان للنازحين القادمين من
العاصمه الخرطوم في ظل الاشتباكات
المستمره منذ 11 يوما
خلاص
[موسيقى]
على كل مزيد من المتابعه والتحليل معي من
الخرطوم الان المحلل العسكري العقيد
المتقاعد محمد جاد الله عقيد جاد الله
اهلا وسهلا بك اي تقييم عسكري يمكن اعطائه
لهذا اليوم على المستوى العسكري من
الاشتباكات المتقطعه وهل تعتقد ان الهدنه
الهشه ستصمد ام لا ايل للسقوط برايك
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اولا دعني
احيي قناتي العربيه والحدث على اتحاد هذه
الفرصه واسال الله سبحانه وتعالى
ان يتقبل الشهداء
من الطرفين والمواساه ايضا للاسره
السودانيه التي تشردت
من وجهه نظري الخاصه بان هنالك مشكله
حقيقيه فيما يتعلق بموضوع الهدنه
وتاتي هشاشه الهدنه من ان قوات الدعم
السريع لا تستطيع السيطره على قواتها او
حتى الاتصال عليهم لابلاغهم بشان الهدنه
هم يرغبون في الهدنه لان هنالك مشاكل
اداريه كثيره متعلقه
بشؤونهم
من وجهه نظري انهم يجب ان نتدخل العقلاء
من ابناء السودان انفسهم ووضع حد
لهذه الحرب العباسيه التي وصفها رئيس مجلس
السياده
وهي طبعا ادخلت البلاد في اتون لم يكن
اكثر المتشائمين توقعا الاماء حدث ويحدث
في السودان حاليا الخرطوم لا تستحق الذي
يحدث فيها هذا
هنالك العديد من الاصوات التي نادت بما
اشرت اليه ولكن لا احد يستجيب طيب عقيد
جاد الله سالتك هل تعتقد ان الهدنه ستصمد
ويمكن ان تمديدها في اليومين المقبلين ام
لا قايله للسقوط
الهدنه
يطلبونها من اجل الممرات الانسانيه
ويطلبونها من اجل خروج المواطنين المغلوب
على امرهم والذين حشروا في منازلهم بسبب
الحرب وايضا نقص الامدادات من المياه
والكهرباء اصبح من العسير عليهم البقاء في
منازلهم ويرغبون الان في مغادره الخرطوم
باي حال من الاحوال ولكن
اطلاق الرصاص
وخرق الهدنه من جانب الدعم السريع يجعل
هذا الامر مستحيل وما يكون من العسير جدا
جدا الصمود الهدنه وفق هذه الظروف
مثلما اسلفت انهم يجب ان نتدخل بعض
العقلاء
لتوصيل رساله للدعم السريع رساله حديثه
للدعم السريع ان يجد وسيله يبلغ بها
منسوبيه المنتشرين في الشوارع حتى يوقفوا
اطلاق النار
هل سيستفاد من هذه الهدنه كما ذكرنا
لتمديدها والبناء عليها ام لا كل طرف
سيستغلها لاعاده موضوعه العسكري والميداني
عقيد جاد الله
[موسيقى]
ان توفرت الاراده لدى الطرفين
سيتم البناء على هذه الهدنه لا احد من
الطرفين الان يرغب في استمرار هذه الحرب
وانت تعلم ان حرب المدن من الحروب المعقده
جدا جدا التي يتجنبها الكثير من القاده في
كل العالم يعني القاده قديما كانوا
يتفادون المدن ليس
لعدم رغبته في السيطر عليها ولكن لان
حروبها معقده والان السودان وضع في مثل
هذه الحرب في عاصمته الخرطوم هي المركز
الثقل الاداري والفني والنشاط الكامل يعني
وهذا بالطبع له تاثير بالغ جدا جدا على
مجمل الحياه في السودان طيب احد عشر يوما
من القتال والمواجهات عقيد جاد الله هل
لاحظت ان طرفا ما حقق نصرا او تقدما على
الطرف الاخر تحديدا في العاصمه الخرطوم ام
لا استتكو ما زال هو نفسه وخطوط التماس ما
زالت هي نفس ممنوع لاي طرف ان يتقدم على
الطرف الاخر
نعم والينا من
معلومه انه هذا المخطط كان كبير جدا
جدا نتمنى نفسها ان يكون
التوقيت هو عباره عن 30 دقيقه
لتستلم فيها الخرطوم كامله بقياداتها
وبجيشها
يتم اعلان يعني الدعم السريع
وقياده كامله
فشلت هذه الرهانات التي رهن عليها قائد
الدعم السريع مع يعني عناصر بالداخل
وعناصر بالخارج ايضا انا من وجهه نظري ان
القوات المسلحه الان انتصرت
وايضا رشحتي لان كثير من المعلومات ان
هناك قوات كثيره جدا
قادمه من كل ولايات السودان هي فرق القوات
المسلحات تقوم الان او ربما هي قامت
بالفعل يعني
بالتحرك الى العاصمه سيتم يعني عاجلا ام
عاجلا سيتم تطهير العاصمه من هذه العناصر
المتمرده ولكن طبعا الجراح عمي الفاتوره
باهضه الثمن من الخرطوم المحل العسكري
العقيد المتقاعد محمد جاد الله شكرا جزيلا
لك على هذه المشاركه اعود الى موضوع وصول
النازحين اللبنانيين الذين تم اجلاؤهم عبر
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وصولهم الى مطار بيروت الدولي معي من ارض
المطار مراسله العربيه ناهد يوسف وكنا قد
تبعنا منذ قليل الكلمه لوزير الخارجيه
اللبنانيه عبد الله ابو حبيب حول هذا
الموضوع ناهد اهلا وسهلا بك جديد المشهد
من عندك وكيف تسير عمليه استقبال هؤلاء
النازحين
نعم نعم طالب يعني منذ دقائق تابعنا وصول
اثني عشر لبنانيا هم هؤلاء فقط الذين
توفرت لهم مقاعد في الطائره القادمه من
جده الدفعه الثانيه ستحضر عند منتصف هذه
الليله ولكن طالب قبل ان نتحدث الى
الاهالي وقبل ان يغادر او عفوا بدا على
شاشه اخرى كنا سنحاول التحدث الى
امين عام الهيئه العليا للاغاثه لمعرفه
الارقام الاخرى التي ستعرض يعني عرفنا انه
الليله سيكون هناك على طائره منتصف الليل
32 شخصا سيحضرون بينهم اثني عشر فلسطينيا
ولكن لديهم وثائق لبنانيه هم سيكونون على
متن الطائره التي ستصل منتصف الليل ولكن
ايضا هناك عدد اخر من اللبنانيين سيصلون
اتباعا اما غدا او بعد غد يعني منذ حوالي
الساعتين انطلقت بهم القافله من الخرطوم
باتجاه بورسودان وبحسب ما علمنا ستستغرق
الرحله ربما حاول اكثر من 10 ساعات لذلك
قد يصل الى لبنان اما يوم غد او بعد بعد
غد طبعا تتوفر لديهم الامكانيات او ان
يكون هناك مقاعد على الطائره طبعا كانت
هناك كلمه شكر اولا للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه والتي كان قال سابقا وزير
الخارجيه انه لولا السعوديه لكن تيتمنا اذ
لم يكن هناك من امكانيه لاحضارهم يعني تم
تامينهم من بورسودان الى جده عبر المملكه
كما تم تامين بقائهم في المملكه منذ يوم
امس منذ وصولهم الى جده وحتى اليوم كلهم
بضيافه المملكه بحسب ما علمنا ولكن الان
يعني نحن بانتظار ان نتحدث الى بقيه
اللبنانيين الذين وصلوا الى هناك سنحاول
معرفه اولا عدد الارقام اللبنانيين لواء
لواء الامين العام العليا للاغاثه اللواء
محمد خير بكره او منذ بعض الوقت او من شهر
ساعتين تقريبا انطلقت قافله اخرى من
الخرطوم الى بورسودان قد ايه عدد
اللبنانيين اللي جايين
حيا الله يعطيكم العافيه لانه
رساله انه لبنانيين وين ما بكون بده يعطي
الرسميه اللي التنسيق اللي تم الهيئه
الخارجيه والتنسيق مع الدول الجوار وخاصه
الدول العربيه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والامارات والكويت وغيرها كانوا حقيقه
تعليمات قويه اعطتنا افضليه اولى نحن نقدر
على لبنان انه لو المملكه تدخلت يمكننا
قدرنا طلعنا اللبنانيه
كنا طالعين نحن اتجاه مصر
يعني دعم مساريه وقريب يعني ما كان
للسعوديه كان يعني تكتيك يعني حتى نسوق
مصر لبناني باقل اضرار وتعباتي لبنانيه
موجوده بالسودان نحن هلا نطلعوا 16 واحد
هون اللي انطلقوا من ساعتين من القافله
اللي ممكن يوصلوا غدا او بعد غد اكيد لانه
هي كوفي كبيره هيدي بس نحن عم نحاول دائما
نكون ضمن قافلات حتى ما يستفردوا على
الطرقات لانه في عندك 1000 كيلو متر مش
هينه يعني بكره بيحكوا لكم
يشوفوها على الطريق يعني وخطورتها يعني
هذا كنا احنا محافظين عدم نشر الخطه حفظها
على الامن القافله
اذا طالب سنحاول ان نتحدث الان الى احد
الواصلين من السودان
يعطيك العافيه
خبرنا اول شيء كيف كانت كيف كانت رحلتك من
السوداني
[موسيقى]
والحمد لله وصلنا بخير وسلامه هل هل خلال
الطريق شو وجهكم شفتوا اطلعوا عالطرقات
الجو حتكون مطرح ما كنتوا كان هالقد خطير
بس على الطريق
الحمد لله بس طلعنا شوي صارت سيف وما في
شي
خلال اقامتكم هناك انتو كل الوقت مخبيين
بيوتكن ولا قدرتوا تامنوا حاجياتكم
اغراضكم اكثر
اذا طالب يعني سنحاول ان نتحدث الى احد
اخر من الواصلين يعني هم ليسوا بالعدد
الكبير لكنهم اثنين عشره شخصا هم من الذين
وصلوا اليوم الحمد لله على السلامه انتم
مين عندكم ابنكم
هو كل فتره بيجي بيطلع عياله بيسافر كنت
مرعب اللحظات قبل ما ينطلقوا كانت مرعبه
كنا عايشين اعصابنا والحمد لله بتقدروا
تتواصلوا معه كان في انترنت تقدروا
بالاوتيل هو كان وضل مزروب بالاوتيل كل
يوم نحكي معهم يقولنا الوضع سيء
الله يسلمك شكرا اذا
سنتحدث الى احد اخر من الواصلين استاذ
استاذ فينا نحكي بس الحمد لله على السلامه
بس نحن على الهواء مباشره
[موسيقى]
يعني طبعا يريدون الالقاء التحيه على
عائلاتهم فلم يعني نحن كوسائل الاعلام لم
نترك لهم المجال كثيرا للتحدث الى
عائلاتهم ولكن سنبحث عن احد اخر
طاقه من الذين وصلوا
نعم
نعم يعني اذا هذه هي الصوره بشكل عام لا
تقدر ناهد ولكن يعني عندما سالت اللواء
محمد حتى هذا مسؤول الوزير الخارجيه عن
عدد اللبنانيين الباقين في السودان عموما
وفي الخرطوم خصوصا يعني تجنب يعني الطرفان
الحديث بالارقام هل يعني ليس لدى الخارجيه
اللبنانيه اي ارقام محدده عن عدد
اللبنانيين الذين ما زالوا في الخرطوم ام
ماذا
نعم يبدو يعني كنا سالناهم هم قالوا بانهم
ليسوا اكثر من 150 لبنانيا هذه الارقام
التي هي لديهم ولكنها ليست بالارقام
الدقيقه فقط لكن
ولكنها ليست بالارقام الدقيقه قالوا انه
كان هناك عدد من اللبنانيين المتواجدون في
لبنان بسبب فتره رمضان وفتره الاعياد
كانوا في الاساس موجودون في لبنان اما
البقيه يعني فقط 16 16 شخصا غدا سيحضرون
او بعد غد اما البقيه قال بانهم ربما هم
ارادوا باعدام الحضور او كانوا في اماكن
امنه الا انها كانت وزاره الخارجيه منذ
يوم امس قالت او اعلنت بانها ستكون هناك
حافله اخرى لها تنطلق اليوم ومن يرغب
بالمغادره يمكنه الالتحاق بها ولن يكون
هناك حافله اخرى بسبب الاوضاع الامنيه
حمد لله على السلامه
ولا يهمك ولا يهمك
ناهد انا ادرك يعني في بعض الناس يعني
الله يوفقكن ويخليكن ويطول اعماركم الحمد
لله على السلامه يا حجه اذا يعني
انا ادرك انه الناس يعني تريد ان نعم تريد
ان يعني ترى اهاليها وبالطبعا انت تقومين
بعملك على اكمل وجه لن اعود اليك في سياق
هذه التغطيه في الفترات اللاحقه من ارض
مطار بيروت الدوليه مراسله العربيه نهج
يوسف شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه المتابعه
النزوح بات الحل امام الكثيرين من
السودانيين هربا من الاقتتال الدائر الامر
الذي دفع مفوضيه الامم المتحده لشؤون
اللاجئين للتعبير عن قلقها من فرار اكثر
من 200 الف شخص الى تشاد وجنوب السودان
وقالت ممثله مفوضيه في تشاد لورا لوكاسترو
انه وصل الى البلاد نحو عشرين الف لاجئ
حتى الان ومن المتوقع ان يتبعهم مئه الف
اخرين مشيره الى دخول 170 الف شخص الى
جنوب السودان منذ بدء هذه المواجهه
وعلى الحدود السودانيه المصريه تستمر
عمليات الاجلاء لالاف من المصريين
والسودانيين عبر معبر ارقين البري حيث
افادت وسائل الاعلام المصريه عن وصول ما
يقرب من خمسه الاف شخص بين مصريين
وسودانيين وجنسيات اخرى عبر هذا المعبر
طويله جدا
كل مخاطر وكده
وضرب شديد حاصل
انفجارات عنيفه وسط اصوات رصاص قرر بانه
يبعد باولاده عن اماكن النزاع بين القوات
المسلحه وبين قوات الدعم السريع
ومش كان بيقولوا في هدنه لكن حتى الهدنه
كان في حرق واضح لها يعني الواحد يتمنى
انه الحرب ينتهي وانه يرجع للامن والامان
للسودان
من معبر ارقين على الحدود المصريه
السودانيه ينضم الي من هناك الاهلي لمزيد
من المتابعه مراسل العربيه احمد عثمان
احمد يعطيك الف عافيه جديد المشهد من عندك
وكيف تسير عمليات الاجلاء وايواء النازحين
نعم مرحبا طالب بك ولساده المشاهدين
بالفعل يعني تستمر عمليات الاجلاء من هذا
المعبر على قدم وساق ربما هناك تفاوت يعني
في عمليات الخروج ربما خلال الساعات
الماضيه الساعتين الماضيتين لم يكن هناك
اجلاء كبير من المواطنين قبلها بساعات او
ما ساعات الصباح كان هناك اجلاء للكثير من
الاسر التي تخرج من المعبر البوابه
الخارجيه لتنطلق في هذه الحافلات للوصول
الى مدينه اسوان في رحله طويله اخرى
تستغرق ما بين اربعه وخمس ساعات للوصول
الى اكبر او اقرب تجمع عمراني على اغلب من
التقيناهم من مصريين وسودانيين راوا لنا
هذه التجربه ربما اصعب ما فيها بان ان من
هم في الخرطوم يتجهون الى هذا المعبر في
حوالي يعني اكثر من عشر ساعات او 15 ساعه
بسبب الاشتباكات حيث ان المسافه هي 900
كيلو متر
التقيناهم اكدوا ان رحله الخروج من
الخرطوم في حد ذاتها كانت هي الرحله
الصعبه كان هناك العديد من الاشتباكات
السلطات المصريه قامت بتوفير ممرات امنه
بالتنسيق مع السلطات السودانيه للوصول الى
هنا ولكن من يتحدثون معنى سواء من الاجانب
الذين كانوا يمثلون وفودا لعدد من الدول
الاوروبيه من اوكرانيا من جورجيا ايضا من
ايطاليا كل هؤلاء اكدوا بانهم سيتوجهون
كمرحله اولى الى اسوان ومن اسوان سينطلقون
الى القاهره ربما لاستكمال رحلاتهم الى
بلادهم اما السودانيون الذين التقيناهم
فاكدوا انهم اغلبهم سيمكسون في اسوان
لفتره لمراقبه المشهد في السودان سواء
التطورات الميدانيه قبل ان يكون هناك قرار
نهائي يعني اغلب من جاء ربما جاء بملابسه
على حد تعبير البعض بحقائب صغيره فبالتالي
هناك من يرى بان البقاء في اسوان حيث
القرب من الاصدقاء والاهل والاقارب
والتقارب ايضا في اللهجه والعادات وايضا
الانخفاض في القيمه الايجار البيوت
والقيمه المعيشيه في اسوان سيكون هو الحل
الانسب بالنسبه اليهم خلال الايام المقبله
قبل ان يتخذ قرار اما بالعوده مره اخرى مع
السودان في حاله تاكل بانه سيكون هناك
بالفعل وقف لي اطلاق النيران ونزيف الدماء
ام انها ستكون ستكون فتره طويله وهذا ما
يحذر منه البعض بان استمرار النزاع سيكون
هناك ربما تدفق للمزيد من النازحين من
خلال هذا المعبر وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن
خمسه الاف من خلال عشره ايام قد يتعرف هذا
الرقم خلال الايام المقبله احمد من يقوم
باستقبال هؤلاء يعني في على معبر رقي
خصوصا يعني رعايه دول الاجانب يعني ليس
السودانيين فقط
وبعض الرعايه كما تعرف يعني يحتاجون الى
تاشيره دخول الاراضي المصريه هل يمنحون
يعني التا شيره فور وصولهم الى هذا المعبر
بشكل فوري ام ماذا يعني ما هي الاجراءات
المتبعه
نعم يعني هذا السؤال يعني بالفعل كنت
تحدثت فيه مع الكثير من المواطنين الذين
التقيتهم فيما يتعلق بالجزء الاول من
السؤال الاجانب فمن يمثلونهم او من
يستقبلهم هم ممثلون من السفارات يعني كنت
فجر اليوم
الذي كان في استقبالهم عند البوابه وكان
هناك متابعه مع السلطات المصريه مع من جاء
من جورجيا نفس الشيء كان هناك الملحق
العسكري من اوكرانيا وغيرها من الدول من
ايطاليا وقبرص وغيرها فيما يتعلق
بالسودانيين فان هناك احاديث ان هذا
الخروج ودخول المواطنين السودانيين
والمصريين عبر عابر المختلفه ينطبق عليها
عدد من الشروط وكان منها عدد من التسهيلات
فبالتالي الان الوضع اصبح صعب جدا لان
هناك تدقيق امني كثير تعرف طالب ان في
الفتره الاخيره او تحديدا منذ 10 سنوات في
بعد ثوره الثلاثين من يونيو كانت المعابر
الحدوديه بين مصر والسودان نقطه الانطلاق
الكثير من العناصر الارهابيه وبالتالي
هناك من يرى بانه على الرغم من عمليات
التسهيلات الكبيره التي تتم يتم فيها
استقبال الكثير من اللازحين من السودان في
هذا المعبر وتقديم التسهيلات الطبيه
وغيرها هناك ايضا تدقيق امن شديد جدا لعدم
استغلال اي طرف لهذه الاحداث وربما التسلل
الى مصر من عناصر خطر قد يكون لها علاقه
بالارهاب من معبر ارقين على الحدود
المصريه السودانيه مراسل العربيه احمد
عثمان شكرا جزيلا لك احمد على هذه
المتابعه
حول الاوضاع الصحيه المترديه جراء
المواجهات المستمره في السودان اعرب اتحاد
وجمعيات الهلال والصليب الاحمر بالسودان
عن قلقه بعد 11 يوما من القتال واكد ان
المنظمه تعمل مع شركائها لاعاده مستشفيات
الخرطوم الى العمل
نحن قلقون جدا بعد 11 يوما من القتال في
السودان وحتى الساعه لا يوجد اي تطور لوقف
بوادي القتال ما يزيد من التحديات
الانسانيه المشكله الاساسيه التي نواجهها
هي العجز في وجود المواد الغذائيه والطبيه
وغيرها كما ارتفعت الاسعار بشكل كبير ايضا
ننسق مع الهلال الاحمر المصري والجمعيات
الاخرى لدعم جميع المحتاجين في البلاد وفي
الخرطوم العائلات عالقه في منازلها
بانتظار الاجلاء نعمل ايضا مع الهلال
الاحمر السوداني والدولي لضمان استمرار
العمل في اكثر من 60 مستشفى وتزويدها
بالمواد الطبيه
الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر جيش والدعم السريع احترام الهدنه
ووقف اطلاق النار والسماح للفرق الامميه
والانسانيه بالعمل وتقديم المساعدات
للمدنيين العالقين اذا كونتاكت خلال
اتصالاتنا علمنا ان هناك عائلات في
الخرطوم لم تغادر منازلها منذ اكثر من
ثمانيه ايام والحركه بشكل عام في العاصمه
محدوده جدا يجب ان يكون هناك احترام لهدنه
وقف اطلاق النار من قبل الجيش والدعم
السريع ايضا سعدنا بنجاح عمليات الاجلاء
للاجانب وعليه ندعو المجتمع الدولي الى
الاستمرار ببذل الجهود وحث السودان على
احلال السلام والسماح للفرق الانسانيه
بالعمل خاصه الهلال الاحمر السوداني
والمتطوعين الذين يتعرضون لخطر كبير هناك
نداءات لحمايه المدنيين وفراقنا التي ظلت
عالقه في مكانها تفاديا للقصف تحدثنا مع
المسؤولين في جنيف والسودان للمساعده في
اعاده العمل في المستشفيات وتوفير المياه
والكهرباء
وفي اخر حصيله جرى للشبكات اعلنت نقابه
اطباء السودان ارتفاع اعداد القتلى من
المدنيين لاكثر من 290 حاله وفاه ونحو
1700 حاله اصابه وقالت اللجنه ان هذه
الاعداد مرشحه للازدياد لعدم قدره النقابه
على الوصول الى المستشفيات وذلك لصعوبه
التنقل والوضع الامني في البلاد
اذا وحذرت منظمه الصحه العالميه من خطر
بيولوجي كبير في السودان وقالت ممثله
المنظمه لدى السودان نعيم القصير قالت ان
الفرق الطبيه للمنظمه تحتفظ بمواد داخل
مختبر سيطرت عليه عناصر مسلحه واتخذت منه
موقعا عسكريا من بينها مواد
مختبريه للملاريا والكوليرا واوبيا اخرى
المتوفره تتحدث عن مقتل 459 شخصا واصابه
اربعه الاف وخمسه وسبعين اخرين لكن
الضحايا اكثر الخطوره ايضا تكمن
بالمواجهات في شوارع العاصمه واعاقه وصول
الضحايا للمستشفيات وايضا تعطيل عمل تلك
المستشفيات كذلك احد الطرفي النزاع سيطر
على مختبر طبي تابع لنا بقوه السلاح وطرد
العاملين فيه واتخذوا منه موقعا عسكريا
بينما نحذر من وجود خطر بيولوجي كبير بسبب
المواد التي نحتفظ بها داخل المختبر بينها
عينات مخباريه للملاريا والكوليرا واوبئه
اخرى
معي من الخرطوم الالي مزيد من المتابعه
الدكتور عطيه عبد الله سكرتير نقابه
الاطباء في السودان دكتور عطيه اهلا وسهلا
بك مجددا الى هذه التغطيه من العربيه اي
تقييم للاوضاع الاستشفائيه هذا اليوم سواء
في الخرطوم او في عموم مناطق السودان وهل
ما زالت معظم مستشفيات الخرطوم خارجه عن
الخدمه ام لا بعض المستشفيات عادت الى
العمل
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته في
البدايه خالص التعادل الجماهير الشعب
السوداني وامنيه الصحه والعافيه
وعوده الحميده لكل مفقودين للاسف ابد من
النقطه التي ذكرها تقريركم ان يعني زياده
استهداف المستشفيات والمرافق الطبيه
والصحيه وهو ما حذرنا منهم منذ اليوم
الاول ان لا يجعلوها منطلق لعمليه
العسكريه هذا خطر كبير جدا الان نحن
المستشفيات لا تستطيع
يعني الاستجابه
للعدد الكبير من المرضى الجرحى نحن ليس
بامكان النظام الصحي ان يستوعب اوبيئه
اخرى بعد بعد الخطر الذي
انذر به تقريركم عن يعني احتلال احدى طرفي
الصراع لهذا المختبر البيولوجي الهام نحن
نحذر كذلك مره اخرى الصراع بعدم استهداف
الكوادر الطبيه هذا اليوم فقدنا احد اعمده
طب في السودان
بشرى ابن عوف الذي اقتلته القدر طعنا
تعازينا لكل اسرته والان يعني بهذا يرتفع
عدد الكوادر الطبيه الذين سقطوا في هذه
الحرب العبثيه الى 13 شهيد
وعدد من الجرحى والمفقودين الان نحن ليس
لدينا احصاء كامل عدد الشهداء يزداد كل
لحظه وحين وهو مؤشر سيء جدا لانهيار
النظام الصحي الذي نحن نراه الان راي
العين لذلك نحن مطالبتنا الى طرفي الصراع
في السودان بايقاف هذه الحرب العبثيه فورا
وعدم وعدم وعدم يعني وضع اي شروط نحن نحن
نريد ايقاف هذه الحرب البسير فورا حتى
يتمكن الشعب السوداني من على الاقل العلاج
الدكتور عطيه لو تعطينا بعض المعلومات من
هو هذا الطرف المسلح الذي لم يتم تسميته
الذي قام بالسيطره على هذا المختمر وهل
هنالك فعلا خطر حقيقي بتف يعني بتفشي
الاوبئه لانه كما هو معروف في مواد
مختبريه للملاريا والكوليرا في هذا
المختبر
نعم هنالك خطر حقيقي في انتشار
انتشار هذه الاوبئه اذا سوى استخدام هذه
العينات الموجوده او تفجيرها من هو طرف
نحن يعني لا علم لنا بطاقه
تحديدا ولكن في عدد من المستشفيات تم
احتلالها من طرفي الصراع نحن لا نبرئ
الاخر
لعدد من المستشفياتها تم احتلالها من
الطرفين نحن يعني كل هذا الرفض لكل هذه
الجرائم الموجهه
الانسانيه وموجهه ضد النظام الصحي وايضا
وايضا المخالفه القوانين الدوليه نحن
نرصدها الان ثم بعد ذلك تاتي الطرق
التحقيق الذي يحدث
منذ اليوم الهذه الهدنه الرابعه وان
استمرت حتى الهدنه المئه بدون ضمانات سوف
تكون هودنه كاذبه نحن رجعنا اوحد الان
امالنا تنحصر فقط في ان هذه الطائرات التي
تاتي لاجلاء الاجانب نستميح اهلها عذرا
ونرجوهم ان يمدونا ببعض من المعينات
الطبيه في هذه هل بالنسبه هنا هنا ايضا
استطراضا لما تقول دكتور عطيه بالنسبه الى
الوضع الدوائي هل ما زالت الادويه مقطوعه
تماما ام لا يعني في بعض المساعدات وبعض
الادويه بدا اتصل تحديدا الى العاصمه او
الى مشاف العاصمه الخرطوم
لا ينسفني جدا انه عدد يعني من المستشفيات
القطع فيها الامداد الدوائي تماما الادويه
المنقذه للحياه المحاليل الوريديه كانت
هذه وحده من اسباب
اسباب توقف هذه المستشفيات من جانب اخر
عدد من مراكز الكره حول السودان ستتوقف في
خلال خمسه ايام ان لم يتم امدادها
بالمعينات قبل قليل وصلتنا يعني انباء
كارثيه عن استهداف مركز الرومي كل الكوادر
المرضى فيه الى الى مستشفى النوم هذه يعني
تصعيد خطير نحن الذين يتحدثون عن وقف
اطلاق النار نتمنى ان نراه على على ارض
الواقع بدلا من شاشات التلفزه العالميه
نعم دكتور عطيه بتعرف يعني اليوم هو يوم
هدنه كما هو معلوم الهدنه هشه يعني شاهدنا
بعض الخروقات ولكن هل يعني في ظل هذه
الهدنه هل
استقبلت المشافي عدد من الجرحى ام لا يعني
حتى حركه التنقل في سياق هذه الادنى ما ما
زالت صعبه جدا
استقبل العدل المستشفيات عدد لا يستهان به
من المرضى والجرحى هي ما اذا ما طالع انه
هنالك عمليات عسكريه بالتاكيد سوف يكون
هنالك ضحايا لذلك
لا يمكن الحديث عن اطلاق نار متقطع هذا
ولو كانت طلقه واحده ترصد سوف يكون هنالك
نريد ايقاف هذه الحرب العالميه فورا وبدون
شروط هذا مطلبنا الان لطرفي الصراع هي
رسالتنا للمجتمع الدولي للضغط على طرفي
الصراع نحن نؤكد ونرجو من زملائنا في كل
القواعد الطبيه ان يقوموا بواجههم الانسان
والمهني في هذا الظرف الحساس بعد ان
يتاكدوا من الظروف الامنيه الممكنه لهم
حتى يستطيعوا الوصول الى هذه المستشفيات
الوضع سيء للغايه سوف ينهار النظام الصحي
يعني في اي لحظه نحن نتوقع ذلك ما لم تصل
معينات ما لم يتم فتح ممرات امنه ما لم
يتوقف استهداف الكوادر الطبيه ما لم ايضا
يعني نتمكن من الوصول الى كل الجرحى
والشهد اء طيب دكتور عطيه بالنسبه الى
الصيدليات يعني هل استغلت يعني بعض
الصيدليات فتره الهدنه لاعاده فتح ابوابها
ام لا ما زال جميع الصيدليات مقفله تحديدا
في العاصمه الخرطوم
اغلب الصيدليات مغلقه هنالك مبادرات من
[موسيقى]
اعزائي المشاهدين في اخر تطورات عمليات
الاجلاء التي تقوم بها الدول الغربيه من
السودان اعلنت الحكومه البريطانيه بدا
اجلاء راعيها من السودان
وذكرت الحكومه ان طائرات عسكريه بريطانيه
ستقلع من مطار خارج الخرطوم تباعا
من جانبه قال وزير الخارجيه البريطاني
لانه لا يمكن اجلاء سوى حاملي جوازات
السفر البريطانيه وافراد اسرهم مضيفا ان
الاولويه ستكون للمرضى او العائلات التي
لديها اطفال او كبار في السن
اما اليابان فقد اعلن رئيس وزرائها فهم ان
فرنسا نقل ثمانيه مواطنين يابانيين من
بينهم مسؤولون بالسفاره
واسرهم من قاعده للقوات الجويه في شمال
الخرطوم
في اعقاب اجلاء خمسه واربعين شخصا الليله
الماضيه بطائرات تابعه لقوات الدفاع
تلقينا في وقت مبكر اليوم تقريرا يفيد بان
ثمانيه يابانيين مقيمين في السودان بينهم
مسؤولون بالسفاره واسرهم غادروا من قاعده
وادي سيدنا الجويه الواقعه الشمالي
العاصمه الخرطوم بمساعده فرنسا سنمضي قدما
من خلال المكتب المؤقت الذي اقيم في
جيبوتي سوف نستمر في التواصل عن كذب مع
الدول المعنيه وسنبذل قصار جهدنا لضمان
سلامه المقيمين اليابانيين في السودان
وتقديم الدعم الضروري
لقد خرجنا الحمد لله
السفينه من بورسودان الى جده حرب طاحنه
قويه
طلعنا من الخرطوم الى سنجه وطريقنا كان في
مناوش طريق صحراويه حتى وصلنا
[موسيقى]
الى القاهره لمزيد من المتابعه والتحليل
ينضم الي من هناك استاذ العلوم السياسيه
الدكتور طارق فهمي دكتور طارق اولا اريد
اي تقييم لديك لمجريات الهدنه هل تعتقد ان
الهدنه ستصمد ام لا عاجلا ام اجلا هي ايه
للسقوط
[موسيقى]
امريكيه دوليه في هذا التوقيت فيما يجري
في الكونجرس الان من استماع ولجان انصات
مباشره محاوله لفرض عقوبات عالم الطرفي
المعادله لن يكون فقط على طرف واحد
وبالتالي ستكون هناك اجراءات راضعه القرار
لن يكون من داخل السودان كما يتصور البعض
يعني البعض يتحدث عن ان الخيار العسكري
مستمر بطبيعه الحال العمليات العسكريه
قائمه لتحسين شروط التفاوض لاحقا لكن
اعتقد انه ستكون هناك ضغوطات دافعه الى
العوده الى حاله الهدوء الهدوء المرتبط
بحاله الهدن الانسانيه لعمليات الاجلاء
المباشره لكن الخطوره
سؤالي لو سمحت لي انه بعد 11 يوم ان من
الاقتتال والمواجهات هل تعتقد ان الظروف
نضجت يعني والوقت مناسب لطرح مبادره
سياسيه للحل بين الطرفين ام لا الامور لم
تنضج بعد يا سيدي هي ليست مبادره انت تبني
على ما سبق يعني انت لديك مرجعيات متعدده
سوف يتم البناء عليها مع تصويب مسار ما
سيجري من من نقاط يعني عالقه جزء منها
مرتبط به كيفيه التعامل مع المسار السياسي
تصويب العمليه السياسيه القضيه مش اتفاق
اطار ولا دمج قوات الدعم السريع الموضوع
اكبر من هذا الموضوع مرتبط به استكمال
العمليه السياسيه دخول اطراف اخرى على
الخط انت تعلم انه هناك ايضا حركات متمرده
لم تلتحق وهي عظم عسكره يعني لدي سلاحها
لم تدخل لعمليه سياسيه فبالتالي في قوه
متربصه بما سيجري الله لن يوجد وسيط داخلي
يمكن ان يحسم واظن انه الاتحاد الافريقي
ليس لديه الامكانيات ولا ولا ايجاد لانه
بطبيعه الحال القوه الدوليه هي من ستتحكم
ليس الاطراف الاقليميه للاسف ان اقول هذا
لا الجانب الافريقي الجانب العربي لا
تفتقد الطولز الادوات او الاليات للتاثير
المباشر قوه الرضع الحقيقيه لدى الجانب
الامريكي بالاساس للتحرك ستكون هناك
تجاذبات من اطراف مجلس الامن بطبيعه الحال
ستشاهد طبعا حاله من التباين الكبير بين
الطرفين لكن في النهايه انا في تقدير
الولايات المتحده بما تملك من ضغوطات
مباشره ستنجح فيه تحقيق موضوع الهدى مع
التوقع ان الخروقات ستحدث وهذا امر طبيعي
لانه اطاله الامد 72 ساعه بعد قليل ربما
ستمتد مع توقع ان كل طرف سيحسن تواجده في
مصارح العمليات لانه حينما سيجلس التفاوض
سيملك شروطه وفق مبادئ وعناصر
العلوم السياسيه الدكتور طارق فهمي شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
اعزائي المشاهدين ازمه غذاء يبدو انها
بدات تتكشف تباعا في السودان اثر
المواجهات المستمره بين الجيش والدعم
السريع حيث نفدت مواد غذائيه اساسيه من
متاجر العاصمه الخرطوم في وقت يتفاقم فيه
الوضع الانساني وصعوبات المعيشه
موعد السودانيين مع وقف النهائي للقتال
يبقى مؤجلا وكافه الرصاصي لا تزال هي
الارجح على الاقل حتى الان المشهد في
العاصمه يبدو مخيفا محل اقفلها اصحابها
بعد نفاذ المواد الغذائيه الاساسيه منها
وتوقف اسواق الجمله عن العمل ومحل البقاله
القليله التي لا تزال تعمل تكاد تخلو من
البضائع والمتوفر منها تفوق اسعاره قدره
المواطن العادي يعني من كل جهه لا كهرباء
الامويه يمكن يشد عليه هنا والخبز اهو
اربعين دقيقه من اربعين الى 60 دقيقه عشان
تقدر اشيل لك
عشر عشرين عيشه
الحمد لله
حامدون وشاكرون رغم قسوه الصراع والاوضاع
الاقتصاديه الصعبه
ما بنقدر نجي منه حاجه لانه
في استغلال يعني حتى لو الباكو بتاع
الدقيقه الليله ب 8000 هيديك قريبا من محل
مواطن كذا يقول لك انت مستقل طوابير
السيارات هذه وكانها بلا نهايه في ام
درمان تصطفوا الى جانب محطات الوقود رغم
يقين اصحابها بخلود تلك الخزانات من اي
وقود ولو توفرت فالاسعار المطلوبه غير
متوفره
ازمات السودانيين تتضاعف مع الانقطاع
المتكرر لخدمات الانترنت والاتصالات
الهاتفيه فضلا عن شرح السيوله النقديه
واغلاق البنوك لتبقى اصوات الرصاص
المتقطعه في هدنه هشه لتزيد مخاوف
السودانيين من اطاله امد الصراع حنان
المصري العربيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات